horror film director Sergio knew Spiller
is investigating reports of paranormal
activity around a mysterious eye deep in
an Argentinean swamp efficiency it's a
perfect formation he has finally reached
the eye shaped piece of swamp he
discovers that it's moving it's very
weird how a silent movie satellite image
analysis confirms new Spillers discovery
as I go through the historical imagery I
can actually watch it move as if it's
following a pattern around the lake the
historical images show the eye has been
here and moving for twenty years every
day the island was in a different
position I believe there's something
that's actually pulling the island
around the leaf
new Spiller climbs onto the eye to
investigate look at the same it looks
for Riya that someone is cutting it it's
like it's loaded look at this the
comforts it's like a carpet the eye
appears to be a floating disc covered in
vegetation new Spiller looks for clues
as to how it was formed we are trying to
go there you saw small underwater camera
and see we can have some features we are
also trying to see if there's something
human built or something new Spiller can
find no evidence that the eye is
man-made but if it's natural why is it
so symmetrical and why does it float as
we walk there are bubbles coming from
the bottom it's met on gas methane gas
is produced by decomposing organic
material and is lighter than air part of
this gas might be one of the things that
helps this island to float floating
islands do exist elsewhere in South
America we do know that up in Peru and
Lake Titicaca there are these unique
structures created by the euro people
there actually reads that are woven
together to form islands and people will
actually live on these floating islands
in the middle of the lake but there's a
big difference between the islands in
Peru and the eye in the middle of the
swamp
these floating islands in Peru require
regular maintenance so that they can
keep their shape because it will
deteriorate over time but this formation
in Argentina there's really nobody
around so how would it keep its shape
over time